hello this is Justin and I'm going to
show you how to counter the most
aggressive openings in chess so first
we're going to start with the Danish
Gambit this is a very popular opening
where white essentially gives away all
of their pawns as fast as possible so
the game starts E4 E5 this is how most
games start and then right away white
tries to give away all of their pawns so
they play D4 and
whenever opponent plays a Gambit the way
to punish it is most likely going to be
to accept it we're going to take that
material and say that they don't have
enough compensation for that material
and that it wasn't Justified so after D4
we just take it and then the Danish
Gambit continues by C3 again gambiing
another Pawn they could have taken that
pawn back but they want to develop very
very quickly this is the
C3 so we take again to punish it we need
to take the material that's how to
punish these gambits so after Bishop
C4 we take another Pawn so we are up
three pawns right now but white is going
to take
back so it's move five but we're already
up two pawns that's crazy like the game
just started and our opponent already
giving away all of their pieces like
it's charity work or something but uh in
this position this is where I feel like
a lot of people struggle they don't know
what to do they don't know how to
develop and it can spile very quickly so
I'm going to show you how to counter the
opening starting from this position so
here we want to play Knight to
F6 Knight to F6 is a great developing
move trying to get our pieces out again
um as fast as possible this is a very
common opening principle we always want
to get our pieces out very very quickly
so Knight to F6 does a great job of
doing that and preparing us to Castle in
the future so after Knight F6 our
opponent kind of has two options they
can either push this pawn and try to
harass our Knight even further or they
can protect it with Knight to C3 so
first let's look at Knight to C3 so
they're protecting this Pawn again
continuing with this theme of very quick
and fast development and to counter this
there's this really crazy move that I
want to show you that isn't very obvious
at all and it's to play
D5 so this is so
counterintuitive because there are not
one not two not three but four pieces
that can take that pawn although the
queen would probably be bad but still
it's a very very controlled square and
we're just moving the piece there anyway
we're we're just saying white can take
that piece back if they want it and
essentially the reason we're doing this
is because we're up two
pawns material doesn't matter as much
what really matters is getting this King
castled getting our pieces developed we
don't want to fall too far behind and D5
is a great way to kind of um emphasize
that that we really need to get
developed we really need to get
castled and White's not just going to be
the one with the initiative the one forc
the issue so after D5 um again white can
take back two different ways or really
three different ways if they take back
with the bishop but we'll look at e
takes
D5 and after this all we're going to do
is play Bishop to D6 we want to develop
our pieces and castle and once we Castle
we pretty much wethered the storm um
once we Castle our King is going to be
safe white is still going to have some
pressure but the main sting of the
Gambit is going to be taken out of the
opening so um if we Castle we should be
happy and then if Knight takes D5 uh we
have to be a little bit more careful
first we want to take with the
knight uh so Knight takes D5 um we want
to be careful not to get too greedy and
take this Pawn on e4 that can be bad
news um in general because a move like
Queen to E2 is already very dangerous
pinning this Knight to the king and it's
already very difficult I think we're
just going to lose this knight uh after
a move like like F3 in the future but
anyway after Knight takes
D5 white takes back and we have this
opportunity to develop with Tempo with
Bishop to B4 check and that check is so
huge because once they get out of that
check we can Castle so when we play
Bishop B4 we're undef defending this
Pawn on G7 and this is a pawn we really
don't want to lose because when we
castle that pawn is protecting our King
and it's it's shielding the enemy um
from infiltrating or position and and
attacking it's a wall um so if we allow
Bishop takes G7 that's just allowing a a
huge gaping hole in this wall and we
don't want to let that happen so Bishop
B4 check is so huge because we we kind
of throw in a punch and white has to
deal with it and once they deal with it
that gives us time to Castle so that was
Knight to C3 we're going to counter with
this crazy move
D5 and essentially again the theme is to
develop and Castle very very quickly so
let's look at E5 E5 is a little bit more
provocative they're attacking our Knight
right
away and again we're going to play the
same exact move it doesn't matter that
our Knight is under attack we still play
D5 D5 is just a a great move no matter
the position because we're striking in
the center and aing our development in
the future so after D5 this looks just
absolutely crazy because they could just
take here and that's what they're going
to do because it's a night that we
didn't they attacked it and we didn't do
anything about it but
here after they take on F6
um we're going to throw in this bishop
to B4 check again this is uh the idea we
saw in the last line and once they
defend it with a move like Knight to
C3 instead of playing DT C4 instead of
capturing this bishop this wouldn't be
great because uh White would do
something like this and then take on G7
they're going to Castle bring their
Knight in the game they still have this
very quick development so even though
we're up a pawn it's very Danger and if
they can hold on to this uh very very
strong Pawn on G7 we could be in some
serious trouble so instead of taking on
C4 we take on F6 this Pawn on F6 is a
serious problem and the reason this
works is because it comes with a
threat we are threatening to play Bishop
takes C3 check because it's supported by
the queen and there's only one Defender
so we're threatening both
Bishop takes C3 and D takes C4 and white
cannot deal with both of the threats um
so it doesn't really matter what white
does um even if they play a move like
Bishop to B5 it doesn't do anything
because we can just play C6 and again
the same problem exists both the bishop
and the Knight are under attack and
there's no way to deal with both of them
so once we reach this position we're
ready to Castle ready to get our pieces
into the game again we've weathered this
storm and we've countered the Danish
Gambit
successfully